KORY JEFFREY:
Welcome, everybody.
We are at Founder
World in San Francisco.
Joining me today in the
studio is Shane Kelly.
He's the founder and
managing director
at Wolverine Angel Networks.
Shane, thank you for joining.
SHANE KELLY: Thank
you for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: Of course.
So tell us a little bit
about your Angel Network.
What makes it different?
SHANE KELLY: I think
what makes us different
is that we actually take
advantage of technology
to bring all of our
investors together.
And all of our
investors, by the way,
are University of
Michigan alumni.
So we're leveraging
that affinity
to bring alumni together
to invest together.
And so that is how our
fund is structured,
and that is very different
than a traditional fund.
And that's why we chose to
use Angel List to structure
our fund as a syndicate.
KORY JEFFREY: So is that how you
found the LPs was through Angel
List, had people subscribe?
SHANE KELLY: No, those were all
through personal relationships.
We just used the
Angel List technology
to bring the investors
together so that we can also
take advantage of all
their intellectual capital,
so that we can put our investors
to work for our portfolio
companies.
KORY JEFFREY: So obviously
the University of Michigan
is a very international
university.
You have alumni all
around the world.
Are the LPs the same
thing, alumni from all
around the world?
SHANE KELLY: Yeah,
you're absolutely right.
I mean, we have folks from Hong
Kong to New York, and you know,
that is one thing that's unique
about our network is that it's
over 540,000 living alumni.
It is one of, or possibly
the largest living alumni
base on the planet.
KORY JEFFREY: So officially
affiliated with the school,
or is it--
SHANE KELLY: No, it's
independent of the school.
It's just all of the
alumni are our investors.
Obviously I go and talk
at University of Michigan,
and I'm not a teacher.
I don't work for them.
But yeah, we're
looking at launching
a program in the
near future that
will get additional benefits to
University of Michigan alumni.
KORY JEFFREY: So where
is the fund itself based?
SHANE KELLY: I say
in Los Angeles,
but our investors
are everywhere.
KORY JEFFREY: So
where do you invest?
SHANE KELLY: Our
first two investments
we just launched
earlier this year.
And our first two investments
are actually in Los Angeles.
But the companies that
we're looking at now
are across the country.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
SHANE KELLY: So we want to
invest outside of the United
States, though.
KORY JEFFREY: So being
an Angel Network,
is it correct to assume it's
an early stage investment fund?
SHANE KELLY: That's right.
We think of it as
everything up to Series A.
KORY JEFFREY: Sure.
And Series A, Valley Series A?
Or Series A, rest of
the country Series A?
SHANE KELLY: Sorry?
KORY JEFFREY: So I find
that sometimes Series A
differs, like I mean
first institutional round.
SHANE KELLY: By geography.
KORY JEFFREY:
Yeah, by geography.
So Series A here
could be $100 million,
and Series A in
somewhere like Nebraska
might be like $1 million.
SHANE KELLY: You're
absolutely right.
And we're really looking
at mostly investments that
are outside of
the Bay Area, idea
being that there is a tremendous
amount of capital here.
So do we want to start
investing up here?
I'm sure we will, but
that's not the target.
It's mostly everywhere
else in the country.
KORY JEFFREY: And
there's a lot of funds
that are doing that
as well, right,
kind of secondary
markets and looking there
where there's less sharks
in the water, right?
SHANE KELLY: Oh, yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: I guess
I'm wondering also,
technologies that you're
interested in investing in?
Is there anything
specific that you
guys like that's
exciting you right now?
SHANE KELLY: No, there's
not a specific kind of focus
that we have to abide by.
The general rule of thumb is,
do we have enough expertise
among our investors to really
add value to the company?
That's the question.
And if we come up
with a yes, then it's
a sector that we can invest in.
It also has to be
capital efficient.
We're not going to invest
in pharma or medical devices
or anything like that.
But there is an area that
I'm really excited about.
There are a couple.
One is entertainment technology.
So I spent several years doing
film finance and distribution
at a start up that raised a
lot of money and really scaled
and had some success.
Injecting technology into
that content lifecycle?
We're definitely interested
in the kind of companies
that are in that space.
The other area I really like
is just simple fact, right?
2/3 of the world's population is
not connected to the internet.
So we're going to have about
3 billion people, some people
estimate, joining the internet
in the next six years.
That is a huge, huge shift,
economically, culturally.
There's going to be
a lot going on there.
So we're looking at
the technologies that
would enable that and then
the application layer that
would run on top of it.
KORY JEFFREY: So building
for the next billion
type of mantra.
SHANE KELLY: Exactly, exactly.
You know, most people think
of just international when
you think about connectivity.
But the truth is that there are
over 60 million Americans who
are priced out of smart phones.
So we can find
those opportunities
in a lot of places, where
once people are connected,
they have access
to education right?
They have access to
Wikipedia and Google,
and it's really remarkable how
that can change someone's life.
KORY JEFFREY: So Founder World.
There's thousands of
people here today.
It's a very busy
and happening place.
What drew you to this event?
SHANE KELLY: It
was really Harrison
who worked for F50
who invited me up.
And he told me about it.
He got me really
excited about it,
and then they really wanted me
to actually moderate a panel.
And I really applaud
F50 for the work
they did in pulling
together an amazing panel.
We had representation
from 500 start ups--
Velorum Capital, Longevity Fund,
as well as the Hawaii Angels.
And so it was really cool to
see the women on the panel, just
really amazing investors.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
And so what were some of
the main messages that
came out of that panel?
SHANE KELLY: Well, our topic,
we really wanted to dive
into the future of
venture capital,
really with a focus on
seed stage investing,
because we're all
seed stage investors.
And so we talked a little bit
about the accelerator model.
And I think one
thing that the way
that investors think about
accelerators is as investors.
KORY JEFFREY: Right.
SHANE KELLY: Right.
We think about accelerators
as being just another model
for venture capital, and
I don't think everyone
thinks about it that way.
So we dove into
that a little bit.
We also dove into Simone
who runs Velorum Capital,
and her approach to
seed stage investing
is in manufacturing and
automation, which is really
thinking outside the box.
And then we had
Laura Deming, who
is investing at the
seed stage in Longevity,
so extending human
beings' lives.
Those are two areas that you
don't often see new seed stage
investors entering the fray.
And I applaud them for
their boldness and vision.
Because when you talk to them,
they know what they're doing.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
So last question, do you have
a favorite Google technology?
SHANE KELLY: You
know, the one that I
use the most is Google Maps.
I would be lost without
it, pardon the pun.
KORY JEFFREY: I totally agree.
It gets me around, for sure.
Awesome.
Well, Shane, thank you
very much for joining us.
SHANE KELLY: Thank
you for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: And thank
you guys for joining us.
We are on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]